[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon six boys
what's up fam how is everybody it is
Monday morning October 31st happy
Halloween parents out there how did you
dress the kids up did you get them going
were they doing face paint did they hate
their costume kids always hate their
costumes they want one thing you put it
on them like I want this thing Boston
wants to be just like his little brother
so he swore to me he wanted to be a baby
T-Rex I got him baby T-Rex he sees his
brother's outfit was fire his outfit his
looks were fire and then you know he
wants to be a zombie from the Disney
series uh zombie that show is lit
lit dude
so that zombie show is on Disney
um there's three movies the first one
came out I think in 2018 but it just
stays relevant because these youngsters
watch them it's a it's it's kind of a
musical you know that's T there with his
friends they dressed up as well from the
movie uh zombie two little cheerleaders
if you're listening to this
two little zombie trailers there's his
bossy as a T-Rex okay super cute as
Tail's awesome his little friend there's
Wonder Woman
yeah he's a pathetic T-Rex huh I don't
know why Boston's Crossing so I T across
his arm because uh Zed does the
character on that zombies movie and I
was like boss dude T-Rex don't cross
their arms I can't do it but he just did
it he just did it man
that's what they did we're coming fresh
off the uh
the fight companion man Cowboys fight
command for Jake Paul Anderson Silva
and am I the only one I was under an
impression the co-main event was Uriah
Hall and Le'Veon Bell that's what I
thought too we had a little bit of a
panic that when that was that fight got
it they started walking out like what
but uh I don't know did they announce
the entire lineup because even when I
was taking Showtime I was told I was the
co-main event I was like one day walk he
said I don't know keep you posted and
then next thing we know it happened what
was interesting I I said this uh when
that fight was announced it's like man
that's I'm more excited for that than I
am the main event
way off if I was not great four rounds
the The Narrative on that is Le'Veon
Bell's uh better box than we thought
um you know for real you're right Holly
definitely should have got him out of
there I think you're at all his little
gun shy and I didn't really pull the
trigger there and but I think the
narrative on that it's not Le'Veon Bell
losing my decisions like Libyan Bell's
pretty damn good you know especially for
having what only this is the second
fight not bad at all not bad at all but
the main event the big uh enchilada of
the night Jake Paul Anson Silva
um you know he took my own horn your boy
called it almost to a T I thought Jake
Paul was going to lose rounds early on I
thought technically he was gonna be at a
severe advantage against Anderson Silva
and I thought that was the case Anderson
Silva had success when he's going
forward throwing faints especially again
Jake Paul against the the ropes against
the the ring there and he did have some
success doing that but but um overall
you know my prediction if uh if you can
go back and watch I think post on
Instagram and we uh posted I said on the
fight campaign and last week's shop show
was Jake Paul was gonna have some issues
with the Anderson Silva early on just
because Anderson's such a technical and
Savvy you know veteran when it comes to
striking and Combat Sports but
eventually Jake Paul's gonna land
something and I thought my prediction
was a late knockout which eighth round
knocked down ain't too far off but I
thought he was going to knock him out
um but he did end up getting the
decision win which if you're a Jake Paul
fan I know some of you are out there
um if you're a Jake Paul fan this was
actually more impressive because you
wouldn't learn too much about Jake Paul
if you went out there knocked him out in
the first three rounds you would be like
well I think the narrative would be
Anderson's old Jake Paul's not that good
yeah of course a young guy lands a big
punch on on one of the greatest ever do
it but the guy is 47 all right Jake just
being up cans by going the way it went
where Jake Paul's losing some rounds
we're seeing how much Jake Paul improved
from his last fight with Woodley to this
fight which is in the the amount of
improvement that Jake Paul's made from
his last fight to this fight really
every fight is insane and it just shows
and it's kudos to Jake Paul for how hard
he works in Camp because to make those
leaps the only way to make those
improvements clearly you're not doing it
in real time in the ring because you
can't fight that frequently so it's
through your training camp and your
coaches so I mean kudos to his coaches
his training Partners the training camp
and for Jake Paul for literally putting
every he selling his body and becoming a
legit boxer because the Jake Paul that
fought Woodley that last one would not
have beat the Sanderson Silva but this
is how fast this kid's getting this is
how good he's getting at boxing because
he's putting in the work he's putting
the time he's taking it serious you know
and that wasn't like uh now is it uh
Anderson Silva from you know 2010 no of
course not but it's a pretty damn good
answer in Silva especially for a guy
with only five fights that's a tough
tough task you know it's Anson Silva who
is coming off a win over uh Chavez Jr
not bad dude not bad so for Jake Paul to
not he needed this he needed it to go
the eight rounds and to to have some you
know rounds where he lost and then also
to get hit and I think as for Jake
Paul's fan base but also for the haters
too you know The Narrative of Jake Paul
doesn't find anybody fighting cans you
know he's just fighting people he has
this huge advantage over you saw a
pretty damn good Anderson Silva go in
there tonight and took it really serious
and definitely won some rounds against
Jake Paul as far as scoring grows at it
77-74 uh 78 73 is pretty aggressive
um even if you had Anderson Silva up on
the cards uh four to three going into
that eighth round
if that's your narrative and that's how
you scored the fight which I think some
people did well that eighth round with
the knockdown be a 10-8 so even with
that assumption which is wrong but even
if you're with that assumption you still
lost if you were betting on Ashton
Simplex that's a 10-8 round in boxing
right so Jake Paul clearly
won this fight very clearly won this
fight
um
you know I I thought his combinations
were impressive I thought
um you know again he only has at this
time this is six fight he had five
fights you know I thought he got in
trouble and and was losing the fight and
and was gonna maybe lose the fighting
decision if he did stay on the ropes too
long and after civil news having success
there Anderson Silva clearly had the
advantage in close Reign box boxing but
whenever it was in the middle of the
Ring Jake Paul really you know got his
feet Underneath Him and started doing
his best work there his uh combinations
his body shots were impressive uh and
then obviously the the big uh punch in
the the eighth round that sat and so
down and clearly put the nail in the
coffin to prove that Jake Paul not only
he's a better boxer but a better Fighter
um and won the fight so
um I think there'd be a little more
controversy especially if you didn't
knock down eighth round people even more
upset but it's pretty hard to argue that
in civil won that fight and I I saw
online I saw article I was reading this
morning of you know Fighters when went
to the decisions like oh here we go it's
like what now you've got to take off
your your your hate glasses I know it's
Jake Paul and listen I'm with you it's
against every fiber in my body as a UFC
alumni Tibet against Anderson Silva
against a kid who came from YouTube I
completely understand the hate you guys
have for Jake Paul especially when he's
fighting Anderson Silva or Woodley
um Ben Astra not really you know a major
UFC fighter but was UFC you know so
I get it I get it
but at the end of the day when you see
what Jake Paul did and you see the
Improvement go go do yourself a favor go
watch Jake's and it's easy to do they're
not that long go watch Jake's fight from
when we fight uh was it Nate Anders uh
Nate Robinson Nate Robinson the
basketball player watch him there and
it's this weird like amateur their their
distance and their timings all off then
eventually Jay catches them and even the
Ben Astro fight we can't learn a lot
from that but then with the Woodley
fights you you want you go back and
watch those five fights again take some
time and do it it's not that much time
out of your day and then watch me
attention Sylvia like oh my God this
improves kids making and what makes that
interesting is because it's tough Ranch
and Silva because remember Silva can
only base
his game plan his thoughts predicated
off those five fights but if the kid's
this young and has this room to improve
you really don't know what you're gonna
get because you can't really expect what
you're gonna get because he's making
these advancements so fast in boxing so
for Anderson Silva he was he was he was
against it man you know because you
didn't fight the same Jake Paul that
fought Woodley that second time you're
fighting completely different fight he's
getting better he's getting better he's
getting better
so um
you know the narrative
of Jake Paul's not real fire fighter
hopefully it's tough to run on that
narrative for the haters out there uh my
favorite is when they go oh it's rigged
it's such it's it's such a low IQ thing
to say it's such a stupid thing to say
because if you hear Ben Astron who
fought him and listen if you fought him
I'm all ears those people say no every
fight's rigged I'm all ears if you
fought him so if Woodley Ben askren or
Nate Robinson come out or Andrew still
came and said that I'm gonna pay
attention if you're a guy who's never
fought in your entire life you have no
background you're just sitting on the
couch and you say it you don't count
right because you have no clue what the
hell you're talking about but what it
does is it discredits Jake Paul's work
but what I find interesting is those
people that say oh this is fake
it it's actually doing more
Pro Jake Paul than it is hurting him
because when you guys go and obviously
Nate Diaz did it right and such an easy
thing to do right it's such a nice thing
to do with Comics these thing to do the
the least creative thing to go oh he's a
hacker he's not funny like you don't
have any original ideas and with Jake
Paul oh um it's all staged you don't
have any original ideas this is it
that's it that's all you got so for even
Nate Diaz right it's easy to jump on
that train he he tweeted a video out
assuming that this answer was on the
payroll it's such a weak [ __ ]
narrative dude it's such because then
okay Nate okay but when you agree to
fight Jake Paul
and if he knocked your ass out what are
you gonna say
oh are you on the payroll like you're
setting yourself up to get a lot of
[ __ ] backlash what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do what net are we
going to run on when you fight Jake Paul
and trust me dude you're not fighting
the Jake Paul that beat Amazon Silva
that night you're fighting a much better
fighter and I'd love to hear from anyone
do you think that the Jake Paul that
showed up and beat uh Anderson Silva
that night wouldn't beat Nate Diaz after
watching that now before this fight when
Jake was not Nate I'm like this terrible
idea I'm telling you don't want these
problems Nate the volume the punching
the cardio the kid can box it's gonna be
a problem man it's gonna be a problem
after that fight like if I'm Nate I
don't I don't know if I want to put my
fan base my
um you know those kind of Optics if the
pros versus cons I don't know what the
payday is I'm sure it's the biggest
payday he's ever had although the Conor
McGregor fights I'm sure you got paid
but
you know I think for Nate it's a real
kind of dilemma now his team's sitting
there and you know obviously they're
gonna say all this stuff in the media
and and also as far as
um being staged or
um being fake you know Nate slapping
Logan Paul's dad's All Stage right we
know this right that's not that's not
real right that builds the fight so
Nate's very good at this right playing
the heel doing the stuff
but you know what I'm saying like she's
good at painting these narratives and
it's all theatrics and I know it's
gangster and we want to use the gangster
thing but it's not very gangster if it's
stage you slap his dad or you know get
kicked out of the Arena stuff like that
right so
um it just builds this fight
but the problem is in Nate Diaz has a
massive fan base so if you keep telling
your fan base this is all faked on the
the they're on the payroll he's not
really knocking these guys out these
guys are taking a fall
well for the most part the educated
people and the the people with a few
more brain cells we know this isn't
staged
but if you keep care on that narrative
and then you guys fight in I don't know
four months my Square Garden wherever
we're gonna do it and he were to beat
you what do you get it looks terrible
so either you're in on it or you just
learned that these weren't stays and you
get your ass beat by a YouTuber either
way it's not good because you've been
you've been ranting and every the fans
and the MMA community's been ranting
it's all staged it's all fake what are
you gonna do dude what are we gonna run
on it just doesn't work but I also what
I think is funny is and I've had people
say listen I was at Starbucks foreign
oh my god dude yeah let me guess you got
a pumpkin spice latte you know like if
you think you'd stay dressed with the
same grown man that ordered some pumpkin
spice lattes right so boy so I think
there what it like what Jake Paul's
doing is so insane and we will never see
this in the as long as I'm alive you're
never gonna see this again a guy go from
Disney to YouTube being the younger
brother of another you know major
YouTuber
reinvent himself go in a different Lane
and go in boxing and beat the caliber of
guys he's beating even though they're
not boxers you know I can see them
beating these guys it's never gonna
happen again he's gonna be the the only
outlier who does this
um at this level you know at this major
level but what I find fascinating is for
those that go it's rigged it's fake
in China do this and I'm with you chin
and Mark could do this Brian would do
this when you see something on Instagram
or Tick Tock or the hell you watch on
social media let's say you see a shorter
guy uh says he has a 45-inch vertical
and he dunks or something like that or
you see a guy do something crazy like
that's not real that that can't be real
that was so impressive that can't be
real that's so insane I can't imagine
another human doing that that can't be
real that's what's going on with Jake
Paul he's the guy that we're watching on
Instagram and he's doing something that
you can't comprehend and it's so insane
what he's doing right now
you have to say that's not real
it's just adding to the legend of Jake
Paul this just adds to it and when he
validates himself where it's not real
against Nate Diaz or whoever he fights
next and you can't carry on that
narrative you literally have to go back
to the fights and go holy he actually
did that to these guys so you're just
bill you're you're promoting this Jake
Paul machine all you that's all you're
doing he has mentioned his name or
anybody for that matter you're just
giving him free promo it just adds to
the The Legend of Jake Paul it's no
different when you see a video and it's
so shocking and you've never seen
anything like it and you don't have the
perspective and you go that's not you
automatically discredit not real
not there's no way that's not real
now sometimes you're right we've had
that gym most time you're right because
you you know you like that remember that
lady who was filming her rescuing kids
getting kidnapped in Brazil remember
they're trying to oh yeah yeah and
you're like yeah actually like dinner
it's not real because it's so insane to
watch like holy [ __ ] though he's a
badass we'll grab that kid and they
caught it all on this [ __ ] video
you're like that's not real it's so
insane that it's insane that that video
catch it but sometimes you will see
things on Instagram where you know
whether it's athletic achievements or
there's some guy in a gym who's holding
on to 100 pound dumbbells and he's like
jumping a four inch vert that's so out
of control so insane we automatically
it's decided because there's so much
misinformation out there go that's not
real
so to me when when I hear that's not
real I go my God yeah how crazy is that
that Jake Paul's been so impressive
knocking Ben Astrid out
when he had two fights knocking Woodly
out
Going the Distance without Sylvan action
they thrown when you guys they didn't
have cardio and power knocking them flat
on his ass it's so impressive the only
excuse
anybody's has out there is that's not
real you're actually helping Jake Paul
in this
that's all you're doing you're just
feeding into his narrative it's nuts
he's so impressed it's to me it's like
dude that's a feather in his cap the
when you say that that's that's a
compliment that's such a compliment
it's the same thing I've had people go
shop don't write his jokes there's no
way they come to the show
and then Mark tell me how this guy you
know thinks she has someone writing your
jokes like damn that's a compliment dude
they think that what do they think Chris
Rock buying them who's random
I'm like oh man that's dope I'm never
like what that's ridiculous no dude hell
yeah man [ __ ] yeah you think somebody's
doing that that's dope dude that's great
that means it's a good show it was so
good you think somebody else is writing
it hell yeah dude this is great this is
fantastic so with Jake same thing exact
same thing exact same thing same thing
with Tom Brady right dude he's whatever
he is 40 14 there's no way he's that
good yeah he's on steroids right we want
to cut the legs from other people
because we could never comprehend that
somebody could achieve these
accomplishments oh my God Tom Brady he's
on so much [ __ ] LeBron did so much [ __ ]
okay
okay just makes it makes you feel better
about yourself
oh there's no way a Disney YouTuber
could not do be down since dude this is
totally staged yeah that's how insane it
is dude that's how nuts it is it's so
nuts
that a good amount of people think it's
staged it's so nuts that a good amount
of people think show time
an Espinoza an Anderson Silva and
Woodley and Ben askren are need money so
bad and are willing to risk their entire
reputations and Stage these fights
when you actually break down think how
stupid you people sound
that it's all staged that everyone's in
on it the Fighter's in on it now let's
say that you want to carry on that
narrative and say well they've been
asking thing to that punch that wasn't
even that hard okay and this is from Ben
Aspen's mouth I think he has a YouTube
show that he does he broke it down he
goes it's hilarious to me when people
tell me that it's staged he goes of
course I want to win that fight he goes
do you realize the amount of money I
would make if I beat Jake Paul it'd be
so short side to go yeah I'll get
knocked out and embarrassing whatever it
was a few seconds yeah let me agree to
that but if I can actually beat him well
his brother's waiting then ideas fight's
waiting the counter fight who knows what
you're gonna get you get probably 100
million dollars or you can take this
whatever it was five million right now
ruin your reputation become a meme have
everyone make fun of you who the [ __ ]
would agree to that now you might be
sitting and go well I would maybe you
would but you're not a world-class
wrestler you're not a former world
champion in two different
organizations in mixed martial arts
you're just not been asking and Woodley
and Anderson Silva would never risk
their reputations and let a Disney
YouTuber knock them out or beat them in
any facet including video games
tick tack toe over the [ __ ] you want to
play they would never do that dude ever
who would do that I think how insane
that is think how stupid you guys sound
right now
they are stupid when you actually think
about it it's insane because the
Anderson beats Jake he goes on a bigger
better things in the long game everybody
who's lost to Jake they don't go on the
bigger better things it costs them a
significant amount of money in their
next fights Woodley beats them he can go
and do other stuff asking me them go on
make a ton of money
Anderson beats him all right man he's
going on doing other stuff when Jake
beats you you get stopped in your
[ __ ] tracks
because nobody really wants to touch
these guys now they get beat by Jake the
YouTuber now you're not gonna get a
bigger fight you're gonna get bigger
payday
so when you actually think about it it
makes no [ __ ] sense it also just
gives so much credit to Jake Paul that
what he's achieving is so impressive the
only narrative you morons can run on us
it's fixed
okay
okay let's take a little break from me
just ranting and raving about Jake Paul
versus Anderson Silva uh San Antonio oh
he thick tour is this Thursday Friday
Saturday tiger thick will be available
next week Houston Texas November 10th
through the 12th heavy taxes Houston
improvs next week San Antonio Europe
this week Thursday Friday Saturday can't
wait to see you guys also stay at my
favorite Hotel of all time Hotel Emma
come get you some well kids Halloween is
here all right Q the Michael Myers scary
music Michael Myers sure is scary but
the last thing you need is be hairy this
Halloween there's nothing worse when you
got a dope outfit but you get your bush
sticking out scaring all the kids
scaring your friends nobody wants to put
you in pics anymore because your wieners
all Sauced up all right thank God for my
friends at manscape launch their fourth
generation performance package to make
sure your pumpkins pumpkins get the
ultimate carving experience on this
spooky day turn your bite-sized treat
into a king-sized candy and and join the
6 million men worldwide who trust
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off free shipping with Coach shop20 make
the right call this spooky season it's
trick or trim we got you baby all right
have you ever tried to trim your nuts
and it turns into a Freddy Krueger film
Freddy Krueger 19 wherever they're on
your nuts are bleeding all over the
place all right who's doing that these
days how many times you heard me talk
about manscape manscape is the only
thing that should be touching your junk
they gave you the performance package
4.0 it's available not just to the rich
for everybody at a great price all right
so the lawnmower 4.0 has Advanced Skin
safe technology it's not gonna clip your
nuts there's no blood no that's the
greatest ball trimmer on the planet it's
also waterproof you knew in the shower
has the light on it the performance
package 4.0 also includes the weed
whacker for those those airs in your
nose and your ears that's scary that's
the scariest outfit you can have you
have hair hanging your nose and ears
what are you doing the weed whacker got
you covered man all right and then they
also to give you their crop preserver
ball deodorant and crop reviver ball
toner will make sure your pumpkins stay
fresh trust me when I say this your
balls will thank you manscape also just
launched a new body buffer that's 100
antibacterial body scrubber it's what
you need to make sure you're fresh and
clean this Halloween manscape even threw
in two free gifts in this performance
package 4.0 the manscape boxes and shed
travel bags and put all that in there
all right so get twins off and free
shipping with the code shop20 at
manscape.com that's schaub20 at
manscape.com for 20 off free shipping
with coach shop20 manscape.com say Trick
or Treat to your beautiful new
Halloweeny with manscaped before we get
back to the program I got to talk to you
about the best nootropics on the
freaking planet from my friends at on it
we talk about Alpha Brain you've heard
it you've heard my friend Joe Rogan says
he feels that it helps inform better
sentences when he's talking it's the
only nootropic that you can trust it is
going to get you into that flow State
what you need to do for a lot of viewers
out there are going to take some Alpha
Brain take two pills and re-watch the
sugar Shawn O'Malley fight and re-watch
Jake Paul's fight and then you come to
your senses and go oh sugar did win and
oh Jake Paul did win it wasn't rigged so
really fire up your brain with some
nootropics and you can save 10 off when
you go to onit.com
everything on the on it website I'm
talking Warrior bars protein powder fish
oil multivitamins workout gear
kettlebells he saved them stuff the
entire website but you can save temps
off Alpha Brain the best neutropics on
the planet it's also caffeine free if
you're worried about trying Alpha Brain
because you're worried about caffeine
don't be caffeine free here's how
positive on it is that Alpha Brain is
going to work for you it's guaranteed or
your money back no return necessary keep
the bottle just let them know you I
didn't like it the refund your money on
the spot no return necessary give about
two weeks we got you covered you have no
reason not to try it save ten percent
off by going to audit.com or swing by
your local Walmart and pick it up but do
your boy a favor go to audit.com shop
thanks for on it being part of the
podcast let's get back to the freaking
program
so what's next for Jake Paul you know I
would assume uh Nate Diaz I would assume
the ideas you know
Dana said Nate goes yeah he doesn't
entertain that he doesn't think you know
he doesn't do he doesn't do circus
fights you do though man the kid all the
kids fight you show up to the events
right you're part of the plan so I would
assume especially with engagement you
know Nate had a fighter on the card do
you guys realize that's all premeditated
you think Jake is needs to fill the card
so bad he's just gonna randomly put one
of Nate Diaz training Partners on there
or do you think in some weird world and
you're the same people that believed all
this is fakes do you think in some weird
world Jake goes all right we need Nate
at the event
Nate's team offered to have their
fighter find the card that brings Nate
in there because and he can get
backstage otherwise he's doing it
backstage so he's calling his guy so
he'll be able to have inner interactions
with Jake Paul and Jake Paul's team
we're gonna have cameras if something
were to happen we'll make sure we get it
to build the next fight do you think in
some weird world that was all
pre-meditated of course it was Nate
didn't in on this quote-unquote as Dana
says circus
I think it's funny I think it was uh
Derek Brunson posted this uh I think
after Jake knocked Anderson down he
threw it out he goes Dana must be smash
this 300 inch TV right now you know
Dana's one man as much as Dana says he
doesn't watch it you know he's watching
Jake Paul especially the card that UFC
put on and compete with this I mean
Grant they did a little earlier not to
compete but still fight card Fight Card
Saturday night I mean not even close
that the UFC fight card was you know
so for Jake Paul I assume it's an ideas
and
you know I can honestly sit and say that
ain't an easy fight for Nate
not an easy fight for Nate at all at all
and even Frank you know this is Frank
Mayer legendary goes even the
counterfeit I don't see Connor beating
him now it's like holy [ __ ] let's get
out of hand that's how impressive Jake
Paul was it makes everybody who in their
DNA Frank Mayer
it has if you open up his if you slit
his freaking wrist and blood came out uh
octagon material would leak out he is Mr
UFC his wife was adamantly rooting
against Jake Paul shoes I just can't I
know Dana listen I believe the UFC I
have there's no way I'm rooting for Jake
Paul there's no way there's no way you
know so everyone's rooting against Jake
Paul and it makes sense so for for Dana
you know it must drive him a little
crazy that Jake Paul's picking these
guys off
and then you know shout out to showtime
for having GSP on at the helm there too
doing his commentating he leaked out
some news goes I'm uh my I think it's
this week he'll be a free agent finally
which is insane and but GSB dig because
you know it would have to be something
really special I don't take any head
shots I don't want to take any you know
damage so I'd have to be right and the
amount of money would have to be right
but you know and not trained for it you
know in full capacity
you know I I would never doubt you know
Jake Paul's team would reach out to GSP
which is insane we're talking about this
that's how insane this is
GSP become a free agent
it's like was he down to fight Jake nuts
it's like nuts but that's definitely not
next Nate Diaz would be next and that is
a banger dude
so uh the payout Jake Paul made 1.5
million guaranteed it's his production
right UFC fighters could take notes from
that he's uh it was his MVP Productions
who put that on in uh Cahoots with
Showtime with the production stuff
but it is MVP production
so he has 1.5 and civil is guaranteed to
pay off I think 800k or 500k 500 500k
but Anderson gets uh
a certain percentage of uh pay-per-view
sales so here it is silver on the so
according to DraftKings Paul's expect to
earn 1.5 million guaranteed all right uh
Paul will have the opportunity to bring
in millions more as he receives ready
for this 65 share of total pay-per-view
buys I would imagine a thing did pretty
well this means the problem child could
walk away with well over 10 million
which he definitely will still on the
hand will earn a guaranteed price of
500k which those 1.5 500 mean nothing
really the former UFC champ Kingpin will
get a 35 share of total pay-per-view
buys
so just so you know the the way the UFC
when you talk about pay-per-view
the way the UFC works is you get uh
Pennies on the on the dollar for
pay-per-view buys with your Brock Lesnar
Ronda Rousey cumberger you get pennies
they're giving guys straight up 65
percent of overall sales and 35 overall
sales which is nutsos so I'd be willing
to bet Anderson probably make you know
I don't know five to ten million
Jake 15 to 20 million off this fight I
would imagine she went pretty viral did
pretty well you know and this also says
syb will also make more money on the
back end through merchandise sales and
sponsorship so yeah that's a nice little
Payday for Anderson Silva man really
nice shout out to Jake Paul but yeah
that Nate Diaz fight the match amount of
money he's gonna make
nuts and for for Jake it's just we're
talking about this on the cowboy event
watch yet it's available on thick boy
right now we had Jesse on fire who
absolutely love Frank Mir and then the
the absolute best in Sam tripley who
definitely got us demonetized probably
get the episode taken down because
conspiracies now here's the thing
before the show and after show Sam
always says uh hey I don't have to talk
conspiracies man I can talk so much
other stuff I'm like I'm sure you can't
you're here talking conspiracies like
that's what I want so whenever there's a
you know I gotta stare the ship so
whenever there's a little bit of you
know there's a slow fight some of those
other fights were pretty brutal so
whenever there's like downtown much look
at him go dude how about the Pelosi
thing and then it's it's Off to the
Races and I know exactly where he's
gonna go so I'm doing on purpose I know
we're gonna demonetize
and I and I I could see Mike who's the
head of thick Boy Productions he's
behind the camera how about the Polish
thing I see his eyes go
because he knows when you get
demonetized and I know it's going to
cost me financially when I do that stuff
but I ca I have to do it I have to do it
I can't and listen I've had
conversations with YouTube and they're
like make sure you don't say this make
sure you don't do this make sure you
don't accustom first whatever I and at
some point like if I start being uh
dising genuine and unauthentic I'm
[ __ ] I have even because my I have I
just it's what I believe I know it's not
maybe the popular opinion online right
now or the facts aren't out but from the
sources and what I see like if this is
what I think is fun to talk about I know
it's going to demonetized I can't change
I can't I know it's going to affect the
show I know the show's gonna get
suppressed which it is I think it's
already over 100k which
as I do about 20K after we're talking
about Newsome and politics and all this
stuff and I think he even called Obama
freaking like uh Obama's born a female
or some crazy [ __ ] I don't know but
that's so much fun to me I'm remember
I'm from the wild west days with Rogan
Eddie Brian and myself where it was on
dude not Steph but back then got
suppressed or demonetized and he was
you're allowed to say whatever you want
and when this weird world now and trust
me I fight it every single day where my
shows are getting suppressed and
demonetized and flagged and taken down
and all this [ __ ] every day every day
and that's just normal to me it's part
it's part of my gig now being a owner of
a business it's insane it's it's
absolutely insane
you know and I don't agree with all the
stuff Elon does and stuff like that but
he bought Twitter I was like God if he
could only buy Instagram and YouTube
that'd be fantastic hey Elon keep the
train going dude get some investors you
know to be tough to buy YouTube and
Instagram because Facebook owns
Instagram but get some investors man buy
that stuff and quit have them suppress
our stuff you know that'd be cool it's a
fight I deal with every day I can't
change I know it cost me money I can't I
don't know what to do I just can't
sorry and I apologize to everyone on the
show even say I'm like hey man I I set
you up for that stuff it's gonna you
know get the show demonetized and
suppressed but that's why you're here
it's literally why I mean this is what's
fun for me and if it wasn't if I have to
change and you know bow down to to their
um you know criteria and what they think
is misinformation or what they think I
can't talk about I I'll just quit I'd
rather retire I'd rather make less money
and just do my thing it's so much fun I
have so much fun doing those things I
hate I can't do a fight campaign next
Saturday for the big UFC uh 281 I'll be
in Houston uh on tour uh Thursday Friday
Saturday that's a huge improv next week
and this week I'm in San Antonio a lot
of Texas Texas is
first two weeks of November so November
3rd through the 5th which is this
Thursday Friday Saturday that the LOL in
San Antonio and then the following week
I'm in Houston November 10th through the
12th at the Houston Improv I'm so
excited for those because those are the
two biggest markets Texas is my biggest
market for Tiger thick so in Houston I'm
doing a parent that specs
um for a while so you can come try the
award-winning uh thick nectar which is
Tiger thick
and a lot of these venues I'm doing
we don't have distribution and so we I I
have to set up and figure out you know
with shipping getting cases there and
selling the bottles and having fans try
it but because it's not officially there
we have to you know and we get Mass ship
stuff Texas is uh already it's already
there it's good to go everyone's gonna
have a chance to try it because that's
no more I meet all these people like the
dude you ran a tiger thing I'm like
literally in the first show we sold out
man because this is an official market
so we can only bring a certain amount
but in San Antonio and Houston we have
all the whiskey all the tiger steak
there so I'm excited for that man that
specs I'll announce soon we're gonna do
a giveaway for San Antonio and Texas
um I'll post it today on my social media
where you're gonna have opportunity to
not only win a bottle of tiger thick but
um also win four VIP tickets at Santo
and Houston Texas so if you're in the
air stay tuned for that pay attention
but San Antonio's this week LOL Thursday
Friday Saturday San Antonio Texas next
next week's Houston Texas at the Houston
Improv and it will do an appearance at
the specs out in Houston on I think
Saturday I'll keep you guys posted and
then the giveaway also keep posted but
it's gonna be dope I can't wait man and
shout out to Calgary shout out to
Calgary Calgary Canada
um some of the best crowds I've ever had
the fans out there man just unreal so
um we're lining a uh a Canada tour up
for next year and we'll be all over man
so I'm excited I am excited man all
right Jim what do you got
now obviously there's a fight night on
Saturday as well yeah Calvin kater and
Arnold Allen
um even with the injury going on it
seemed Arnold Allen was kind of he I'd
say he won that first round the
commentator goes for that jumping knee
blows his freaking knee out and then
with the light kick it was just it's
tough for Calvin you know it sucks to
see someone go out like that the Arnold
Allen train keeps rolling
um with what's going on the
featherweight division with volkanovsky
fighting um Mark Chev you know that
leaves the guy in um uh Emmett Josh
Emmett so Arnold Allen Emmett makes a
lot of sense there that's why I'd like
to see and shout out to my boy Cleo
Roundtree for fighting uh Dustin Jacoby
who was ranked Roundtree wasn't in
Jacoby I think he's been on a seven
fight win streak so to get that nod is
insane and I know Split Decision a lot
of people thought Kobe got robbed on
that but I'm such and I love Dustin but
I'm such fan of Cleo and that's my guy
so I'm just glad he got the win but
Arnold Allen Josh Abbott next you're
welcome
what do you got Jen all right you
mentioned the whole conspiracy people
think that you know the whole fight
rigging thing so I have like like two
different things for you on that one
someone I had a bunch of people send me
this someone named Rodney sent me this
in particular so if you look at this
you see that punch right there
so keep going it looks like it almost
just passed his face didn't really touch
him but this is one that's getting a lot
of views this one not this one in
particular but there's there's a bunch
of videos here you're getting like
millions of views so it's picking up a
lot of steam but then if you look at
so I'll play this so this already has
3.2 million views right watch
it looks like it just barely grazes his
nose right sure does from this angle
from that angle but if you're the
official angle and watch this one so so
pause it real quick so all this stuff is
confirmation bias right so how many
angles they look at until they're like
oh this doesn't look real you probably
went through 10 different angles nine
out of 10 showed and silver can knock
the [ __ ] out and land on his ass I saw
on the live broadcast yeah you saw it I
mean it's insane so the but the
confirmation bias which feeds this
narrative that's rigged how many angles
did you go through if you had to go
through the majority of them where it
showed them getting actually punched and
then you finally found one that works
for your narrative you piece of [ __ ] and
not only that people nowadays we don't
know people can doctor videos so it can
make it look like oh for sure because
it's not a clear video it's kind of like
and what's interesting too is you know
we live in this this world of social
media where I always tell people it's
not real
um you know like think how much Hate
Machine Gun Machine Gun Kelly gets think
how much hate Drake it's weird they sell
out every venue though if so many people
hate them why are they selling every
venue out why are their album sales
trending number one all over the place
it's so strange
if social media was so real how these
guys making a living honest Chris Pratt
so straight yeah she keeps getting
booked for movies it's so weird so with
Jake Paul like if you had to go through
how many different angles and then
you're gonna doctor it
potentially doctored definitely doctored
but what's interesting too many doctors
to a weird angle look at that oh weird
that's his fist in his face but you'll
see here right here
it definitely hits his face there
it's pretty obvious oh man that looks
doctor no this is this angle you can
totally tell you guys right in the
[ __ ] face of course I don't even need
to see that without knowing they
[ __ ] those so I assume those two are
doctor just a weird angles weird angles
yeah but why don't they show that one
and like the first comment on this was
the The Knockout seems edited
okay
but what's weird about this
you know and even if you go to the
Pelosi thing notice the the major media
outlets and when I say major I guess the
the historic major ones like
Fox and CNN stuff like that none of them
reporting this but to get the actual
what's great and bad about social media
is those other alternative uh
information details come out only on
social media because Fox and CNN can get
sued if they run with a narrative and
they're not 100 sure and they don't have
you know
several journalists yeah sources and
stuff like that but when you when you go
through the other stuff like credible
people are putting out a canister and
stuff like that or whatever whether you
think's credible or not but just outside
of her and you get these other factors
you're like man why aren't these news
outlets reporting and then you realize a
lot of our news is coming through social
media good and bad a lot of it you're
like oh when you find out the other
facts of certain situations like Jesus
this is nuts like the Jesse Smollett
stuff
people on Twitter were calling [ __ ]
from the like even black people like
this seems fishy but then Fox and CNN at
the time were kind of riding with it
because they have to and then our
politicians were riding within Kamala
Harris and Biden were riding with it
saying this is ridiculous and I can't
believe America blah blah blah right but
the social it was the head of the game
going oh it smells fishy and then we
find out that it's pretty fishy you know
so it's good and bad
because because you know you can see
this on ESPN that it's doctored or fake
or anything like more crazy angles yeah
no but the confirmation bias online it's
tough because now you can run with a
snare so but you said that 3.2 million
views of that fake one yeah that was
when we watched it this morning at 11
A.M you know by tomorrow who knows six
million views well if six million people
see that and think that's real and think
it's fake it's just it feeds in that
narrative and I told you guys
if you go back and listen when I started
ranting about this I told you guys
this is only gonna hurt you're you're
setting yourself up for complete failure
because if you think Jake Paul all his
fights are staged and all of it's fake
and your huge Nate Diaz fan he's the
original real Gangster and then Nate
fights him and if Nate gets beat what
are you gonna do that means Nate got
beat by a guy who's actually not winning
any fights but then for the first time
in your mind because you've been
compromised by social media
the first time ever finally has to take
a real fight Nate ain't gonna take no
fall he's gangster he's ganks I hear
this he's gangster
and then if Jake beats him what the [ __ ]
you literally people's dicks are gonna
explode
excuse me nuts literally they're
literally like oh I saw that video
online I thought it was fake this whole
time it's not
I made money on my YouTube without
faking narratives oh my God
what are you gonna do
what else you got you all right um this
is a really quick one so James Vick he
would I guess you know he was I think
let go from UFC yep went to karate
combat so he lost his first fight party
combat but
we're gonna Robin black
um boss rutin GS I think gsp2 yeah
they're all part of cardboard which is
cool but I just thought this looks cool
this is his fight but just the
background it looks like a movie you
know yeah it looks cool yeah looks very
Mortal Kombat 90s Vibe and now it's gone
but yeah oh why'd they take the video
today I don't know or maybe it's just
mine player nope it's already gone but
we saw a little bit of it
um
oh this this I thought was kind of crazy
too so you're at all before the fight he
had a press conference
um he said he was dealing with
depression after he left the UFC he said
because he's what 20 years into the game
that's all he knew he says a lot of
athletes Fighters probably deal with the
same thing hey everyone uh soldiers deal
with the pts yeah because that's not
only the PTSD but you get done and you
have the strict lifestyle even in sports
whether it's football basketball hockey
soccer baseball all this stuff MMA you
have this strict schedule and you have
this you're you're trying to achieve
this goal and then once that's over you
wake up like I don't have anybody I
don't have a schedule man and then
depression comes and it's it's dark yeah
he said everyone deals with it he said
he got to a point where he was looking
at his firearm and thinking like you
know the he could potentially end his
life luckily he had people around him to
yeah people around them but I mean yeah
that's something that I guess retired
Fighters and retired people from that
are athletes everyone deals I mean think
about when when you graduate college you
know that weird like gray area right
you're looking for a job it's scary and
you don't know what the future holds and
you have this degree and you're told if
you agree that you get this job and then
it's not really happening for you in
this gray area like that's how these
guys feel but they're a lot older they
don't have youth on their side to figure
it out and backpack through Europe or
where the [ __ ] these you know kids do
you know so for the fighter it's like
all right I'm 36. I don't have a ton of
money in my account I have a certain set
of skills I guess I'll go teach karate
you know it's like what do you do yeah
of course they're depressed it seems
like it happens mostly with athletes too
because they're Windows smaller than
hell yeah and soldiers think about that
yeah that too
um all right so this is also interesting
well I'll just play this clip for you
this is Jake Paul telling Dana White to
suck his dick hilarious yeah let me
refresh this real quick
I think Jake doing the stuff against
Dana like like I compared you know on
Shawshank Redemption nobody's cheering
for the ward and the guy who has it all
already nobody it's hard to cheer for
Dana even though he does a lot of great
things but whenever a guy who has less
even though Jake has a significant
amount of money but still less than data
Dana's set and didn't have fight for his
money so it's hard even though if you
dislike Jake Paul
to root for Dana when they had their
beef
you gotta be real sociopath through for
the guys that everything you know sits
in Newport and his neighbors Mike Tyson
and Conor McGregor you know and he's
this dictator of Fighters stuff to root
for that guy you know so Jake Paul doing
this is good okay let me play this is
from anime junkie man look at the makeup
on their civil's eyes it's like they
faked that
so he got punched in the face for real
yeah
Dana
Dana look at Anderson
Dana
bro
you said I wouldn't do this and I did it
and with flying colors uh but you know
he's in hiding you know he he's trying
to do everything he can to stop my run
to sabotage my fights he hates me he
hates me he hates what I'm doing he
hates I'm exposing his business and now
you know
we're going to band together and create
a United Fighters Association to help
UFC fighters all MMA fighters and and
boxers to get more fighter pay long-term
Health Care
um good luck and that's a big big
undertaking that I've been wanting to do
for the whole entire
of my career since I met nakisa you have
a better chance beating Canelo than you
do get a fighter let's switch this Crush
Line's apple cider
yeah I mean Dana hates this [ __ ] you
know what's next for me if he beats Nate
you know I don't know what they're gonna
do
um
so mad Dana White can suck this dick
I love Anderson because you know
Anderson you know he's had his issues
with Dana and you know they've been
business partners he's just like oh God
you know she's Anderson's such a nice
guy you know he doesn't really do that
so uh Jake even said beforehand that
Dana has been trying to stop people from
knowing about this fight obviously
people don't know about the fight but
he's been doing a bunch of stuff even
like cease and desist letters because
Jake was promoting the fight with some
clips of Anderson so he wanted to stop
all those clips of Anderson from the
yeah
so there you go it's a shark at the top
who if he doesn't like you he'll do
anything he'll try to stop you yeah I've
been there my man this guy Dana in the
UFC were sending me Seasons assist lives
this whole entire week to take down
YouTube videos where we had highlights
advanced in the UFC and Surround upon
which is all over the internet right but
their lawyer saying that it's a seasoned
assist he's doing anything he can to try
to mess this up on this fight weekend's
clear he has some sort of Vendetta
against me and maybe you Anderson as
well of course
look at the way they're treating it in
his videos look at the way they're
treating uh
uh Hardy
oh Dan Hardy yeah
devalue them and assume that he's a you
know woman beater and it's just like Dan
Harmony's like what in the [ __ ] yeah
he's like that's what they do they
always do this they try to sabotage my
business they try to devalue me so I
don't have any worth after I leave the
UFC like it's what they do man
yeah but this day and age with the
internet stuff like that it's gonna be
tough
it's gonna be tough trust me I've been
there I've been there yeah everything
will come scored out of [ __ ] you know
UFC now Studios it was hilarious and fox
here oh yeah and fox it just won't let
him back in oh that's funny yeah that's
funny um so this is also another thing
Jake Paul said that Dana White banned
him from UFC events and he had um
stylebender on his podcast and they're
talking about this so I'll play a little
bit of it for you
look I'd say good skill Jake good skills
before the fight by the way and just
keep doing you man keep doing
you
like it's fun to watch and we'll tap in
later on yeah we'll type it later on I
think we're gonna do for a catch up 100
bro I'll I'll maybe pop into New York or
some [ __ ] like that hey let's go you'll
find MSG oh [ __ ] I'm banned yeah but I'm
banned from UFC events [ __ ] I can't why
Dana
Dana banned me after they all were
yelling [ __ ] Jake Paul in the stadium
and then I tried to go to a different
fight and all of our tickets were or
decline banned and then like his
assistant was like get the [ __ ] out of
here get the [ __ ] out of here and like
escort at the event at the event at the
event and then Dana White's son
apparently I didn't know who it was at
the time he's like I [ __ ] hate you he
was like drunk off of some [ __ ] like
wearing some suit and he was like [ __ ]
you and he was he was using like racial
slurs against me
um and yeah that was like yes sorry I
get I forgot I can't come but damn
that's wild but yeah
yeah so I guess he's banned from the
event what do you mean Dana White son's
not a good person
we don't know we don't know no no no
it's fine he wears suits and calls
people the Edward
we don't know what he said uh all right
so this also was kind of surprising
stand-up guy this was surprising to me
Anthony Smith so in this article BJ
penno comment says Anthony Smith
encourages anime fans to boycott Jake
Paul's future fights and he's saying why
are we still pandering to this pizza
that's weird and I mean I can kind of
get it trust me I get it let's see
um
we should all boycott the rest of his
fight until you find someone who's on
his level or whatever level we deem him
to be will be fought to the level that
the internet deems him to be Anthony who
would he fight
I'm sure
you know what I'm saying like do you
guys think he's the worst of all time so
who should if he predicate based off the
internet he won't even you guys wouldn't
allow him to fight so that's that's
silly you talk a lot of [ __ ] about anime
facts about you see then you pretend
that you want to bring fires up and you
want everyone to get paid better but you
trash everyone every time they fight
um
but he didn't trash Anderson he had a
lot of respect yeah
um
for the boxer saying older shorter
smaller past prime legs don't have to
spend their entire careers running
ruining their bodies into [ __ ] car
accidents pulled you guys near and do
our hearts go [ __ ] yourself like or even
Panda speak [ __ ] yeah I think after the
hate he should stare towards other
people you realize the answer made more
money in this fight he's ever made would
they made more of a funny more money
than he's ever made been asking made
more money he's ever made not also he's
not good then why is he beating these
guys and then he's also advocating for
fighter pay he's the only one with this
magnitude of a platform to even get
close to Bringing attention to it so I
would say he's doing a lot more for the
UFC fighters than anyone has ever done
so so the hate towards my I I get it
because Auntie Smith has so many fights
he's such a good fighter and so many
fights I would be willing to bet Jake
made more off financing civil than it
then Anthony has his entire career so I
can get I get I understand the the
Hostile take there you know but it's
kind of I'd point the The Smoking Gun at
somebody else unfortunately he's not the
one yeah and I was talking to case
earlier like it's kind of it kind of
sucks for people to say
you know don't watch the you know say
like promoting people to not do this
because they think because it's their
opinion that their you know Jake Paul's
a bad dude whatever but why shut someone
else down for doing their thing just
because you don't like it correct it
makes no sense it's also not gonna work
again I tell you guys this you're just
promoting Jake Paul so Anthony Smith
he's like let's not promote him but you
talked about you know so that's
promoting yeah and people aren't cheap
they're gonna be like I'm actually in
tune in this maybe if even if even the
team get beat up you're still paying
Jake Paul you know yeah
okay well you already know about this
but
so
I guess the original idea was for Jon
Jones to fight Stipe in December right
December 10th
but apparently something's going on with
Stephen but Jon Jones says he's still
training and still wanting to fight on
that card even though you're prohaska
and lover chick Sarah like the main
event and what I was told by somebody
who deals with these guys is if we hear
Yuri and uh Glover are in the rematch
Jon Jones off the card there's one out
of the two and they're waiting for
steepe to sign he didn't so you get the
announcement of Yuri that means John's
not buying this card they didn't want to
put both of them on the card there's no
one else for John other than in Ghana
but he can't do it right yeah yeah
interesting
you do John versus Sarah God
yeah but I mean damn
it'd be so much cooler oh I know that's
what I'm saying yeah so anyways
yeah
it'd be more stupid is more like a
legendary fight just John taking over
you know
oh man it's a it's a tougher fight for
John yeah sir guns in his freaking Prime
footwork and stuff would be interesting
definitely be a tough tough task for
John out of anybody yeah true I'd love
to see it I just wanted to fight for
God's sakes I'd watch him fight the the
50th ranked heavy with the FC right now
yeah but like you said he's asking
stupid to sign the contracts there's
some going on with Stipe in the UFC
apparently where he's not signing the
contract interesting
um you already mentioned this too but
just thought I'd throw it out again so
GSP says his his contract with the efc's
over he can do whatever he wants now so
we'll see what happens with him I don't
see George doing the uh
the Jake Paul stuff no he doesn't want
to get he's talking about damage he
doesn't want to do do that and this is
this is funny from Sean O'Malley he said
he rewatched the fight he goes
definitely one great put a heart emoji I
agree and then since then Daniel Cormier
he says he's been hearing stuff about
Peter Yan because you know Peter on he
lost a split to al-jamin he had the DQ
because of the knee and then now this
Sean O'Malley thing he's saying that he
thinks that UFC doesn't have his back so
he might want to do something else and
not I mean UFC doesn't want a Russian
Champion during these times yeah
I don't know but so that's what Daniel
says because he's Russian yeah good
chance
you know
hmm
that's what you gonna do with that you
can't fight in Russia
definitely can't fight in Russia no not
right now
what do you do with that face your face
of uh you know that division's ration
with what's going on right now it's
gonna be tough to Market you think
Americans gonna get behind that
you're American audience
can't advertising uh rush for the most
part I don't think
from a business standpoint
I'm I'm a patriarch like I'm [ __ ] out
of here dude
if it goes decisions you guys want me to
lose
who knows how deep it goes so those are
his last fights right there
yeah that Sterling the decision splits
tough
um and then Sean O'Malley split my only
caveat it's not like he got robbed on
any of them but you can see how the
other guy would get the nod and how if
he was like he was clear as danger I was
like oh my God yeah the fix is in dude
get out of there go fight somewhere else
where you're not fighting it out you
know the fight peteron's fighting is
that would be outside dock gun if he's
getting robbed then my thing is he
didn't get robbed on those two yeah it
was close but if you think that Dana
White wanted those scorecards to read
Peter Young you're out of your mind but
Sean's like yeah he checks way more
boxes unfortunately for Peter John he
checks all the boxes
all right some fight announcements Bryce
Mitchell and Ilya yeah I love that yep
they're both 282 so that's in December
and they're both undefeated so that
should be good
and then there's also
that youngster with the face the face
yep yep 18 year old Raul Rosas Jr he's
gonna fight a guy named Jay Perrin dude
18 yeah that's his debut fight in the
actual UFC the bum brought UFC 281 is
you don't get a
uh bow nickel because he got injured
yeah
I was looking most forward to that fight
uh so the young kids fighting Jay Perrin
who lost his last two in the FC
but I mean that makes sense kid's 18. no
no no I'm sorry yeah man give the kids
and they want him to blow up for sure oh
yeah yeah but let's see who he should be
fighting guys like this for a long time
at 18. yeah and here's a quick one so we
mentioned last week that Bellator
they're gonna have five other you know
best fighters fight and ryzen so these
are their opponents I don't know their
opponents but I'm just looking at their
records it seems pretty evenly matched
as far as the records are concerned
right so producers three thirty four and
five say that name
Kim
yeah it's like roughly the same yeah so
it should be good it's gonna be fun yeah
and it's cool that they're actually
doing that because they're tough um
besides Roberto de Souza those other
ones are tough tests yeah
um all right here is
I'll just play for this is uh Henry
sahuto calling out algeman algae May
Sterling signed the contract Perth
Australia
's funny just put no
I'll show you I'll show you an update to
that too
but either way sign that damn contract
so that's what no yes who don't wanted
that and then aljamin this is what he's
saying pretty much
he doesn't want to fight until mid next
year because he's earned it he's been
fighting I agree yeah do you think
you're the champ Val do your thing dude
I'm with him he's like no
is this kick rocks
no
kick rocks and then since that happened
now sahudo's asking for your boy
um hey Dana White since Denzel Sterling
wants to work on his rap career he can
be called little power how about me
versus Ronald McDonald
for interim Australia I'm I'm short so
I'm used to being down under
yeah I don't think no yeah
I sure you're just gonna wait for the AL
Jermaine fight and you know next year
there's no way he'd take the fight
against go for this yeah Championship so
who does it nightmare matchup for both
of them it's a tough fight sudo's a
monster
and this is uh Conor McGregor live
stream check him out right now
he's lean too
and he's out of the testing it's holy I
love this
[Music]
yeah y'all he does look giant yeah like
still lean it's insane good for him
I wonder what he is there though
it's super funny it's a meme the movie
was in I don't know and I can't even
find Derek Lewis's Instagram anymore I
feel like it's gone like something
happened Instagram took down a bunch of
accounts randomly uh they don't know if
it was hacked or what but so it just has
made friends with this guy before the
movie started just in case
dude he looks identical to the shooter
of Dark Knight in Aurora Colorado my
home theater my mom lives about five
minutes from there
[Music]
it's hilarious and then this one here
this was on Bellator I don't know the
fighter I try to find his name but I
couldn't find him but he did like a
wolverine you see this oh and he even
went for like the [ __ ] like like he
actually had claws
yeah I don't know if he won or lost but
look this is crazy
but what was this
what was his plan I have no idea
but it just looks insane to do that well
but also when like when he reached do
you think he's gonna get like a double
leg do you think he was like had claws
just to shock the guy maybe I don't know
I mean end up screwing him
yeah I think that's pretty much it what
did what did uh Fury say about Jake Paul
oh yeah there you go and Johnson and
Tommy feared Tommy Fury was apparently
talking smack after Jake Paul won
because he's fighting an old dude but
Tommy Fury pulled out two times from the
fight so well I mean the nerve there
then listen uh Tyson fear is my my
favorite fire in any Combat Sports but
and I love him but hey man you didn't
let your little brother who let's be
honest Furious he's not very good he's
Dime Piece great reality star not a
boxer you know Jake with a mob stuff at
this point and you guys prevented him
for fighting him so when you go he's
fighting old people you're like okay
well he tried fighting your brother what
happened
you just prevent it from happening
you're the only reason he didn't come
out here
what's this this is just Logan Paul
saying he wants to fight um Andrew Tate
it's more of you know
uh what he what he talks like I mean
they're listening to him say something
that actually makes absolutely no effing
sense or it's a statement so bold that
it's repulsive
um I think people understand what to us
was very clearly Saturn sarcasm as like
a respect or liking to Tate but I've
never liked Tate I find him amusing the
same way you find a clown amusing maybe
I would take the opportunity to platform
him just for one night just for one
night and turns his freaking face Inside
Out have him wheeled home or Gurney with
his brother holding his hands in the
ambulance type [ __ ] I don't I don't like
you I want to F you up
for Logan Paul yeah oh you're talking
about the guy who's a former world
champion kickboxer now I don't know
Andrew Tate but if I'm just going off
the the p's and q's here if I'm going
off black and white skill set I don't
know if you want that Logan you know
that that a tough one
tough one two very popular dudes though
so I'll probably do decent yeah do well
uh you have a fight night fight nights
have been tough let's just call what it
is you have Rodriguez limos obviously
they want Rodriguez to get a title shot
um but the best find the cards the
co-main event Neil magni Daniel
Rodriguez I love that fight Daniel
Rodriguez coming off you know that fight
with uh the leech uh last second
replacement you know Magnus won this
fight so I'm all about it
cool
so enjoy those but uh I probably won't
be watching I'll watch that one probably
on Sunday it's not a good enough card to
try and set up an ingredient that's
always a nightmare but I'll be in San
Antonio speaking in Green Room San
Antonio this Thursday Friday Saturday at
the LOL tiger thick will be available if
you're not in Texas and can't come try
that award-winning sweet thick nectar
you can get it online at thickboy.com
get delivered to your doorstep and then
next week November 10th through the 12th
is Houston Houston Improv Houston Texas
I'll be with sinat specs I think it's on
Saturday I'll announce all that on my
social media while also doing a giveaway
for San Antonio this week the giveaway
for uh Houston uh the following week
um we'll blast out on tiger thick and my
social media where four people can get
VIP tickets and uh tiger thick we're
gonna do a dope giveaway so pay
attention on there to win free tickets
at the show and uh tiger thick and then
I close November in Milwaukee Milwaukee
improv November 18th through the 19th
all the touring for oh he think tour for
20 22 is Providence Rhode Island
December 1st through the 3rd and then
Washington DC DC improv's December 15th
through 17th get your tickets at
thickboy.com get your award-winning
sweet nectar at thickboy.com we got it
all there new merch we're dropped new
merch this week for the thick boy diet
teas you've seen me rock them around we
have hoodies long sleeves and tees get
you some love you guys Happy Halloween
eat some candy for me I have cavities I
can't touch them my teeth are all messed
up so eat candy for your boy here uh be
safe out there make sure you go through
your kids Canyon for Fentanyl and uh
love you guys
till next time I'm out